el expresidente es acusado de abuso de
poder de diseminar noticias falsas con
fines electorales y de atacar las
instituciones democráticas el Tribunal
Superior electoral sustenta estas
acusaciones por causa de una reunión que
bolsonaron mantuvo en julio del año
pasado con varios diplomáticos
extranjeros en ella sin aportar pruebas
crítico el funcionamiento de las urnas
electrónicas y sembró dudas sobre todo
el proceso electoral en Brasil su
defensa alega que esta reunión se
realizó antes del proceso electoral y
que por lo tanto no constituye delito
sin embargo de última hora se ha
incluido en el juicio un documento que
fue encontrado en el despacho de su ex
ministro de Justicia ahora mismo en
prisión domiciliar sería un plan
detallado de golpe Y aunque en este
juicio él no es juzgado por esta razón
este documento puede ser decisivo para
demostrar que su con los diplomáticos no
fue Simplemente un acto improvisado sino
parte de un plan muy detallado para
perpetuarse en el poder
Valeria Por qué se dice que este juicio
Define el futuro político del ex
mandatario
la decisión del tribunal superior
electoral puede ser decisiva para el
futuro de bolsonaro porque podría quedar
inhabilitado durante ocho años y volver
a la vida política activa solo en 2030
con 75 años pero es mucho más grave que
eso porque la decisión de esos jueces
podría influenciar la de sus colegas En
la Corte Suprema donde Jair bolsonaro
tiene seis juicios abiertos el más
importante su supuesta responsabilidad
en el intento de golpe del 8 de enero
los jueces podrían entender que
bolsonaro está realmente atrás de todo
este destrozo que vimos en la plaza de
los tres poderes Y ser considerado el
autor intelectual la defensa de bolso ya
ha dicho que va a recurrir una
hipotética decisión del tribunal
superior electoral en contra de su
cliente sin embargo vemos a un bolsonaro
bastante mentalizado con la idea de ser
inhabilitado y sabemos que el futuro
político de este ex presidente puede
quedar mermado aunque no sería la
primera vez que sentencias muy
contundente es en Brasil se han anuladas
por instancias superiores o en periodos
diferentes Lula es el mejor ejemplo de
esto